Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Je ne sais pas où vous êtes en ce moment.
Peut-être en vacances, sur le point de partir ou de rentrer.
Peut-être faites-vous partie de celles et ceux
qui ne reviennent jamais les mains vides.
Un petit souvenir qui trônera quelque part chez vous.
Je me suis dit que c'était une bonne occasion de
vous raconter l'histoire de certains objets
qui décorent mon atelier et que j'ai rapportés
pour la plupart de vacances ou de voyages.
On commence par ce drôle de caillou.
Je vous en ai déjà parlé sur la chaîne Épicurieux.
Je l'ai ramassé sur les pentes de l'Etna, en Sicile.
C'était pour un tournage de l'émission C'est pas sorcier.
Après une nuit à la fois extraordinaire
et infernale pendant laquelle j'ai
assisté en direct à ma première éruption volcanique.
Je pourrais vous en parler pendant des heures.
Tout a commencé aux alentours de minuit.
On avait été prévenus par les volcanologues
qui m'avaient précisé
que nous étions à 500 mètres du cratère,
que le cratère lui-même faisait
500 mètres de hauteur et que la fontaine de lave,
au moment de ce qu'on appelle le paroxysme de l'éruption,
mesurait elle aussi 500 mètres de hauteur.
Je vous promets qu'à ce stade, on sentait la chaleur de la lave.
On sentait également une petite odeur de soufre.
Au petit matin, on est rentrés sur Catane,
la ville la plus proche où nous étions basés.
Une partie de l'équipe, dont j'étais,
a fait un bout de chemin à pied
et c'est là, sur les pentes de l'Etna,
que j'ai ramassé ce drôle de caillou.
On appelle ça une bombe.
En fait, il s'agit d'un lambeau de lave projeté en l'air
qui, en retombant
parce qu'il était liquide, a pris la forme d'une goutte.
Quand on le soupèse, c'est très dense et ça se voit très bien
quand on regarde à l'intérieur
parce que le même jour,
j'ai ramassé celle-ci qui s'est fracassée.
En fait, cette bombe s'est brisée en deux
quand elle a touché le sol et on voit très bien l'intérieur.
On voit que c'est très dense.
En fait, c'est du basalte, le même basalte que l'on utilise
sur les routes ou sur les voies de chemin de fer.
Et puis, on voit aussi qu'il y a des petits trous à la surface,
comme des petits cratères.
Eh bien ça, c'est la trace du dégazage.
Quand le lambeau de lave s'est retrouvé en l'air,
il était plein de gaz et ce gaz est remonté à la surface
et en sortant, il a laissé ses marques.
J'ai acheté ce mug
au Canada à bord du Pierre Radisson, un bateau.
Ce bateau, Il s'agit d'un brise-glace
qui, l'hiver, navigue sur le fleuve Saint-Laurent.
Nous avions embarqué
dans le cadre d'un numéro du Monde
de Jamy consacré au froid extrême.
Le Saint-Laurent est le cordon ombilical du Québec.
Les navires marchands l'empruntent
pour alimenter une partie du pays.
Le passage doit donc rester libre en permanence.
Le Pierre Radisson sillonne donc le fleuve et
dès que la glace se forme, il accourt et brise
d'énormes morceaux de banquise
pour libérer le passage, de jour comme de nuit.
Il y a même un hélicoptère à bord qui patrouille
pour repérer d'éventuels obstacles.
J'en profite évidemment pour vous expliquer
comment fonctionne un brise-glace.
Contrairement à une idée reçue,
ce n'est pas la collision frontale
du bateau avec la glace qui brise la glace.
La coque à l'avant du navire est recourbée vers l'extérieur.
Le bulbe a une forme convexe qui permet au bateau
de grimper sur la banquise
et c'est le poids du bateau qui brise la glace.
Le bateau doit donc mettre les gaz pour
profiter de son inertie et en même temps
se dégager très rapidement pour ne pas,
à son tour, être pris par la glace.
C'est très impressionnant, surtout le bruit.
Vous entendez ?
C'est le bruit de la glace qui se brise.
Je suis à bord du Pierre Radisson, un brise-glace
qui sillonne le Saint-Laurent durant tout l'hiver.
C'est sur ce bateau que j'ai tourné
ces images qui sont devenues un GIF. Énorme !
Quand je regarde ce mug, je repense bien sûr
à ces longs moments passés sur le pont, malgré le froid.
C'est pour cette raison d'ailleurs que c'est un mug thermos.
Voici une plaque émaillée
en forme de triangle, ce qui signifie "Attention : danger !"
avec un ours polaire à l'intérieur.
Alors bien sûr, il s'agit d'un fac-similé,
mais c'est la reproduction
d'un panneau de signalisation
que l'on croise à tous les coins de rue
à Longyearbyen, le nom de la capitale
de l'archipel du Svalbard,
situé ici, dans le cercle polaire.
78 degrés de latitude Nord.
Pour info, le pôle Nord se trouve à 90 degrés.
Logique, la Terre étant une sphère,
en partant de l'équateur, latitude zéro,
on parcourt 90 degrés pour atteindre le pôle Nord.
Le cercle polaire, lui, est une ligne
imaginaire au-delà de laquelle,
pendant une période, il fait jour ou nuit, suivant la saison
24h sur 24 et plus on se rapproche du pôle,
plus cette période est longue.
78 degrés de latitude Nord,
ce n'est pas très loin du pôle Nord
et jamais je ne suis monté si haut.
Quand j'y suis allé, c'était début mai.
Il a fait jour durant tout le voyage.
Je vous promets que ça fait très bizarre d'ouvrir les yeux
à 2h du matin
alors qu'il fait grand jour comme en plein après-midi.
Mais revenons à la première plaque, celle avec l'ours.
Effectivement, cet animal est présent sur l'archipel,
y compris dans les rues de Longyearbyen,
où il s'aventure régulièrement pour chercher de la nourriture.
C'est un animal très dangereux, au point que là-bas,
les habitants se promènent avec une carabine en bandoulière.
J'ai même vu des étudiants rentrer de l'université
avec une carabine sur l'épaule.
Je vous promets, ça surprend.
Alors, la question que vous vous posez maintenant,
c'est est-ce que j'ai vu l'ours ?
D'abord, je dois préciser le contexte
dans lequel je suis allé là-bas.
C'était il y a quelques années, dans le cadre
d'un épisode du Monde de Jamy
consacré à la cohabitation homme-animal sauvage.
Pour observer l'ours dans son milieu naturel,
nous nous sommes écartés de la ville.
Une journée de motoneige.
Tenez, là, c'est moi.
Bon, on a un peu de mal à me reconnaître sous la combinaison,
mais je vous promets, c'est bien moi.
Et là, c'est la cabane de trappeur dans laquelle nous logions
avec l'équipe, nous étions accompagnés par deux guides
un Français spécialiste de ce genre de milieu,
Nicolas Dubreuil, et un guide norvégien qui, lui, était armé.
Je vais vous raconter maintenant
ma première rencontre avec l'ours.
Nous étions donc arrivés à destination
et en discutant pendant le repas,
le trappeur qui nous hébergeait
nous informe qu'il avait vu des traces le matin-même
de l'autre côté du fjord.
Du coup, aux environs de 23h,
alors qu'il faisait évidemment grand jour,
nous décidons de sortir les caméras et de nous équiper.
Bah oui, il faut quand-même rappeler
qu'il fait aux alentours de -20°C
et qu'avec la vitesse des motoneiges,
la sensation est plutôt de l'ordre de -40°C.
Nous enfourchons donc les motoneiges
et nous décidons d'aller tenter notre chance.
Alors, après environ une demi-heure de trajet,
nous repérons les premières traces.
Il faut dire qu'elles sont assez faciles à repérer
quand la neige est immaculée.
Dans mes souvenirs, ensuite, nous n'avons pas eu à chercher trop longtemps,
mais ce n'est pas l'ours que nous avons d'abord vu aux jumelles,
mais sa proie : un phoque immobile
sur le sol, précédé d'une longue trace rouge.
Nous descendons des motoneiges et nous approchons.
Nous sommes cinq.
Il y a deux cadreurs, deux guides, dont un armé et moi.
On constate que le sang est encore frais.
Le terrain est très vallonné.
Le guide norvégien propose alors à Stéphane,
le réalisateur, de faire le tour du monticule.
L'ours est sûrement de l'autre côté.
Avec Nicolas Dubreuil et Richard,
notre cadreur,
nous avançons un peu, puis nous nous arrêtons
et nous nous allongeons dans la neige en silence.
Nous sommes à environ une trentaine de mètres de la proie.
Nos camarades, eux, ont disparu derrière la colline.
On attend.
Et puis d'un seul coup, surgit devant nous,
pile dans l'axe du phoque, l'ours.
À ce moment-là,
il est à une cinquantaine de mètres de nous.
Il y a une autre arme,
mais elle est restée dans le coffre d'une motoneige
qui se trouve à une centaine de mètres.
Trop loin.
Nous ne bougeons pas.
L'ours, je m'en souviens, nous regarde.
On ne filme pas non plus,
l'objectif de la caméra pourrait stresser
l'animal et là...
Alors Nicolas est quelqu'un de très grand.
À voix basse, il nous dit :
"À mon top,
on se lève, on agite les bras
et on hurle de toutes nos forces !"
Message reçu.
L'ours
s'avance vers nous, vous savez,
de sa démarche très assurée.
On attend le signal.
Quand l'ours arrive au niveau de la proie,
il s'immobilise.
Il se trouve maintenant à une trentaine de mètres.
En quelques secondes, il peut être sur nous.
On ne bouge plus.
Lentement,
il saisit sa proie
puis fait demi-tour et disparaît derrière le monticule de neige.
On attend encore un peu,
puis le calme se fait dans nos têtes
et je vous promets qu'à ce moment-là,
le sans cesse de frapper dans mes tempes
et je pousse un grand ouf de soulagement.
Cette nuit-là, croyez moi, j'ai très bien dormi.
Nous n'avons fait aucune image de cette rencontre.
Les images, elles sont dans nos têtes.
Quelques jours plus tard, nous avons recroisé un ours.
Cette fois, nous avions pris toutes nos précautions.
Une fois encore, l'ours s'est approché très près de nous.
Nous avons filmé
et là, j'ai pu prendre quelques photos.
Je vous propose maintenant un peu de chaleur autour du feu,
ou plutôt autour d'un kit
pour lancer un feu, comme le faisaient
nos ancêtres au néolithique.
On me l'a offert pour le tournage
d'une vidéo spéciale "Classe grandeur nature"
consacrée aux gorges de l'Ardèche.
Le lien est ici. Une très belle expérience
dans un lieu exceptionnel,
la Cité de la Préhistoire, à deux pas de  l'Aven d'Orgnac.
On y découvre le mode de vie de nos ancêtres
en contemplant des reconstitutions
et en reproduisant des gestes vieux de 10000 ans.
De quoi est-il constitué ?
À l'intérieur, on trouve deux pierres,
du silex et de la marcassite.
La marcassite contient beaucoup de fer.
En percutant l'une contre l'autre,
on produit des étincelles. Pour faire du feu,
il faut aussi de l'amadou.
C'est très, très doux.
En fait, c'est un champignon,
l'amadouvier, il pousse sur les troncs d'arbre.
En tombant,
les étincelles mettent le feu à l'amadou
qui se consume assez lentement.
On pose ensuite les braises dans un coquillage,
quelques brindilles,
on souffle un peu et on obtient de belles flammes.
J'avoue que le geste pour produire des étincelles
est assez technique.
L'autre méthode consiste à utiliser un
support en bois comme celui-ci,
dans lequel on a pratiqué au préalable
des encoches. Un bois assez tendre, du pin ou du sapin.
Il faut aussi une tige rigide
taillée dans un bois un peu plus dur
et un objet comme celui-ci.
Attention, ce n'est pas un arc.
On coince la tige dans la lanière, puis on place
la pointe de la tige à côté d'une encoche.
On la tient bien à la verticale
en appuyant au sommet, en s'aidant d'une coquille.
Puis, on utilise l'arc comme un archet.
La tige entre en rotation et creuse la planche.
De petits copeaux s'entassent au niveau de l'encoche.
La rotation génère de la chaleur qui met le feu à la sciure.
On la récupère.
Coquille Saint-Jacques, brindille, souffle et le tour est joué.
Alors, après la visite du musée
et cette expérience, surtout, ne manquez pas
la découverte de l'Aven d'Orgnac.
Je n'ai pas de mots pour décrire cette grotte.
C'est un festival de stalagmites et de stalactites.
Les concrétions prennent des formes invraisemblables.
C'est vraiment très, très beau.
Inoubliable, l'un des plus beaux spectacles
souterrains que la nature ait produit.
Voilà, j'espère que vous avez passé un bon moment.
Tous ces objets sont merveilleux, bien sûr,
mais les meilleurs souvenirs
sont les images que nous gardons
en mémoire de nos vacances.
D'ailleurs, je me disais : ce serait peut-être
bien, pour l'été prochain,
une petite série autour des souvenirs de vacances
avec des têtes connues de YouTube ou d'ailleurs.
Qu'en pensez-vous ? J'attends vos commentaires
et je vous dis à très bientôt !